i would like to begin the class today
for on um
uh opposite color uh bishop and
endings or end games same thing
why such topics for today uh i
thought i found uh recently i mean more
like overless of course over the last
couple of days
um some interesting end games that have
been played during this
opera uh rapid um
champions chess tour and um
i thought it would be interesting to
review some of them and um
not only for let's say my own knowledge
but also
uh i felt like it would be good idea to
share with with
the viewers on the channel of the
sandwich chess club and
some and basically such end games are
usually considered as drawish right
because opposite bishops and
you know always have those drewish
tendencies
however it is not always the case and i
prepared several examples
in which
i analyze uh different scenarios what
can happen
in uh in different types of
end games with opposite color bishops
depending pretty much on the pawn
structure
so the first game i wanted to start with
uh is the one
that actually i lost uh and this is the
game i lost to
uh sam shankland in 2019
it was summer chess classic uh in
general to give the context about this
game it was
a very long game 100 moves the game was
like six hours i guess or something
and after the opening at a very bad
position and uh
ever since i was always on the defensive
side some made some mistakes
and he could have finished me even
before time control
then i somehow
got some chances and someone i was
probably even close to making a draw
however in the end we got position
which was uh i thought already
pretty close to being drawish and
uh perhaps it was however i made some
again some mistakes and i had the
possibility to trade into um
go into let's say optical bishops and i
did go for that
so let's see what happened so uh in
general what i would like to
discuss at first is position after
knight xb3
so uh i don't i want to go into detail
but essentially uh let me just double
check everything it works everything
works okay
so essentially uh i'm down uh okay not
i was always down the pawn here uh i got
a pawn back
right now temporarily but after king e3
followed by bishop takes before i'm
gonna lose this pawn again and while we
have two connected
passports and supported by the pair of
bishops of course
there are certain chances for for
a while to win this game and i had some
chances here to save this
uh i don't want to go into detail how
exactly and what
what matters for let's say from from for
the sake of this uh this
lesson is that but and the opposite core
bishop engine which
i achieved after bishop g6 and now g4
so here some for sure he had known uh
and i didn't know at the time
uh the intricacies of such endgame and
here i thought i still have some chances
to make a draw base
exactly on this move idea of knight d3
because 93
right now is a big i thought is a big
threat
that he cannot allow because this
immediately trades uh
bishops uh i mean trades my knight for
the bishop and enters the opposite
bishop end game
with only one extra pawn and even though
the pawns are connected
uh evan evan g pawns are connected i
thought that i have pretty good decent
chances to save it
because i will be able to bring my king
quickly to the king side blockade the
pawns
maybe upon uh the deep would be sort of
like
um
and deflecting white bishop or white
king from you know supporting response
and i will make a draw somehow however
things are not so easy and
actually after g4 and id3 and then takes
degrees of fd3
portion is still lost and this is i
think very instructive because even
though it seems like
it's very very close to being to it
being a draw
uh it is lost and the
the reason why it's lost is the next
wise next move if i had one more move
here and i got to play
i get to play the sake in d5 yes it will
be probably a draw
however if white is to play white plays
king e5 first so here is one of the
say rules about in general end games
king's activity king
always uh in and maybe not always but in
majority of situations
king in the end games king has to become
an active piece
and the king if after king e5
i not i do not really lose this d4 pawn
i i mean i will lose this pawn and
probably anyway but i can still defend
the same bishop e2 or something
but the main problem right now is that
why they will manage to push response
very comfortably forward uh g6 obviously
no deficit is not to blockade the pawns
and i cannot allow i cannot stop this
and uh
finally after those moves f4 f5 g5 g6
king will come to g5 pawns uh and then
for f6 and loads of ideas connected with
f7
then pro very likely uh there'll be some
spanx and so on so let's see what
happened in the game how
i lost and um
let's say let's learn from it king d7 f4
this is pretty much nothing i can do the
only way to i thought to stop this for
spawns was to bring my king to the king
side
uh and this is let's say you know this
is an idea but it's not sufficient
just get into xd4 which will be 2 and g5
and
seemingly it should be a draw sort of
like it
may feel like because um
it's only two pawns right and if only i
can give one my bishop for those two
pawns it should be a draw
um it will be a draw however it is not
possible in
such instance because g6 is pretty much
unstoppable if bishop h5
anytime i can just play move king e5 and
there will be some tuk fuk in the end
uh that i will have to let go of g6
a square and uh i will lose so after
this let's say king f4 and let's say
finally bishop c3
this is the first suk's funk and there
is no way to stop g6
because king has to leave g7 square
sorry f7 square can go to g7
and bishop also cannot stay here forever
that's why i cannot stop g6 so after
bishop b5 king e5
i try to keep my bishop from e8 in uh
with an idea to basically
uh after bishop c3
you know after getting i mean obviously
from d3 idea in general
was to uh kind of you know stop
f6 f7 this is because i have to somehow
stop uh six of seven so either i have to
keep my bishop on d3
uh x-raying the spawn on g6 or keep my
bishop on e to put bishop uh
you know some uh what's impression just
g6 pawn in this way
after we should be free key in g5 bishop
c4
uh f6
actually white is winning because uh the
king right there is no
i i have to stop somehow f7 right with
black and
i cannot same time hold f7 and
put pressure on uh the pawn on g6 that's
why
uh if i cannot in time to bring this
bishop here
but the thing is and even if i was in
time to do it for instance
uh i because i could have let's say gun
for position after king e5
let's say bishop e8 king bishop c3 let's
say bishop b5
king of 4k and g8 and right now let's
say not bishop d3 by bishop e8
nothing would have changed because in
this position
and that's a king h6 and again i mean
such funk because uh
the bishop they cannot stay on this
diagonal too much
if this bishop had one extra square
let's say you know
up the board right it wasn't the back
ring already but
it was one more square let's say
somewhere on the d file
um hypothetically it would be a draw
uh for instance if let's say we move
those pawns
upwards pawns to f5 uh white pawns to f5
g5
king to h5 and the black king to g7
of course while we have light square
bishop and black will have a bishop on
e7
then it will be a draw maybe it's a
little bit abstract when i'm trying
talking right now but basically
uh then i have this extra square on d8
uh
if we move let's say you know uh
volvo spawns on the fifth rank
everything by down down the file then
there
will be d8 square and this will be a
draw because there will be no way to
break through
however in this particular instance it
will be
simply lost
so in the game for bishop d3 and the
king g5 f6
and right now king f8 which should be
for checking
g8 and essentially right now the king
simply
goes sorry goes on the dark squares
around to e7 and i cannot stop f7 and
the game is just decided
so this is exactly what happened king f4
we should be freaking e5
bishop c4 bishop b7 not necessary but
sufficient king d6 bishop c4 is waiting
in place king d8
finally bishop comes back king e7 and
here i resigned
because finally white place f7 and i
cannot stop this there is no absolute
absolutely nothing i could do
and that's how i uh lost
the game so this is the first game i
wanted to
to show even though it seems like it
seemed like there was
it was very close to a draw it was not
close enough unfortunately
uh even like going back to the beginning
of this end game
let's say in here those pawns are only
on f2
f2 and g4 so
it may seem that they should be somehow
stoppable but
because of the such active king on e5
they vote spawn and my
my own king very passive on c6 you
should have been already last year on g6
to
try to you know make a draw here
uh i think that the game uh this is
already lost
i mean i know this is simply lost
because of this backing on c6
so uh yeah very very instructive
uh i learned myself after this game that
uh
you know even though seemingly with two
pawns and
um the such ending of two pawns are not
trivially drawish nice lesson
painful lesson but nice one from some
here in this game
all right so next game i want to talk
about uh is my game against
turkish grand master dastan and
in this game i on the other hand i won
and the the position i wanted to talk
about is this the following one
let me just double check if it showed up
show that all right
uh so just double check yeah okay
so this game was played in 2017
and this is okay i have two extra pawns
and um one pawn is on b5
which is the past pawn which is very
nice uh very important factor
and but there is no other any other
passport on the king side therefore in
this position
the only plan the white wood white can
do is to apply the rule
um of creating second weakness pretty
much
because right now uh with only one past
pawn on the b5 let's say even if this
for instance if the king comes to
the case black plays the king of six
four in the game king of one
the same goes move like king k7 if white
base let's say basically brings the king
to c4 or something like this like he's
looking 16 d3
this didn't happen in the game by the
way but uh you know
okay bishop b6 let's say king c4 okay
what what next i'm just bringing my king
to c4 but there is no breakthrough here
so it means that the only way the only
path to supposedly even win this
is to create a second weakness somewhere
on the king side
and to do this i somehow start pushing
my pawns forward and i have to do it in
a very skillful manner
uh because if i get to let's say
block my pawns uh if you black because
to block my pawns i will not be able to
win it for example
one good let's say a strategy to win
this let's say after bishop b6 of
this display move g4 h6 and bishop c6
slowly
start pushing f4 e4 and so on in general
in such end games
uh they're another apart from creating a
second weakness rule
uh there is applies a rule also about um
creating
uh sorry do not hurry
the rule do not hurry this rule
basically implies that
one should not rush things uh in
you know and you know decide on things
that are
pretty much you know premature and uh
in instead one player player with
disadvantage should focus on
gradual improvement of the position
rather than you know forcing matters
here
and uh and exactly that's with a proper
strategy for white
in general white needs to create a
second pass pawn on the king's side
and this pawn should be as far as
possible from the pawn on b5 so the
further
the better with some caveat which i will
talk about in a second
uh so let's say after king doesn't
happen again in the game
uh it's a king e7 uh is f4
f6 let's say e4 and after e5 for
instance you know
let's say one may try to block locate
the pawn structure here
so right now it would be a big big
mistake to let's see if they play after
e5 it takes e5 and d5 to create this
pass pawn
because right now those pawns are very
close to each other unless after g5
everything is blocked suddenly even
though white has two extra pawns that
position totally blocked and there is no
way you can win this
however if you play d takes e5 f takes
e5 and now
f5 you actually are creating a pass mode
is far away
from this one and there is a wave
through with
for the king with king c4 king d5
of course black will try to play king d6
but at some point
uh there should be some sort of uh
tux funk which will allow us uh to win
the game eventually
and phrase after g5 takes takes king c4
king d6
uh one can play maybe bishop d5 without
the already bishop
of playing f6 and after bishop d8 we can
play maybe move like
uh some let me just think maybe king b4
for instance
and the point is that the king cannot
move because then king c5 follows
uh very often or another possibility is
to play during bishop g8 or something if
king goes here i'm going to play king d5
and this is winning another possibility
uh
you know if bishop f6 there could be an
idea of you know
just pushing b6 b7 and king d5 even
sacrificing the pawn and just promoting
uh the f-pawn
[Music]
in general those spawns the as they are
so far
away from each other black is not able
to hold them both from
going forward and allowing white king to
invade um
this is in general what what should be
white's strategy
uh in the other level let me show uh
what happened in the game after king of
one might
play with e5 immediately so uh it's also
logical to
try to simplify the position and again
would be a huge mistake right now for me
to play with d5 even though
one might say okay in the pawn and in
the in the end games it's better to
keep more points on the board and keep
less pieces
and so maybe 10 you play with d5 but d5
on the other hand
you know creates this kind of uh
possible blockade on the dark squares
and we never want to play in d5 in such
position with white that's why i played
detail c5
the king 35 king e2 slowly improving the
king
h6 bishop c6 and f5
and um okay sooner or later i was
beginning pushing my pawns
and this pretty much doesn't matter this
is again generally winning for white
however that nice technique
the appreciation pretty nice technique
uh how to win it so that's why i
would like to bring this game that's why
i'm bringing this game up bishop e8
so right now um um
pawn g6 is attacked and if black plays
move for king f6 uh this king will be
very
passive and he'll be forced to be
defending pawn on g6
and i'll be able to bring my king
quickly to d5 and so on so
the only way to stop them my king from
coming to the file anybody playing with
g5
which turns pretty much the same as in
the game
so the bishop e8 power black play anyway
g5 in this position
and here i think i present pretty nice
technique because i simply took on g5
tag on g5
and i'm playing with f4 so i keep
trading more pawns but what i
accomplished by this
is actually i'm i'm gonna have uh a past
pawn here
i'm actually creating a possible just
far away from uh
from the b pawn so the question here is
um
okay king of six followed and
right now a very important move is after
g5
if g takes f4 i have to say that nothing
uh
changes pretty much and i would take uh
with the e pawn
and uh after king f6 let's say or king
ge6 doesn't matter let's say king f3
eventually i'm gonna play with g4 and
then i have
more than uh you know more than enough
here
distance between those pawns to
basically win it in general the further
uh the further those points are from
each other the better and
let's see let's say for example for this
example in the example y
for instance let's let's let's say let's
say black plays king e7 bishop c6 king
f6
now let's say g4 takes takes so right
now
again there are two past pawns and the
white strategy in general
right now is to make sure that both are
protected and then
threaten white king to go to either of
the pawns
and because those pawns are so far away
from each other black
king and uh and bishop cannot defend
both at the same time
um for example let's say bishop b16 is
normal
i will just play bishop b4 for example
bishop c5 you know black cannot do
anything just have to wait
bishop d3 and king f3 just has to wait
bishop a7 let's take in e4 king e6
uh f5 for instance or
maybe bishop c4 to be more precise
suddenly there is no
good way for the king nowhere to go with
the for the king because if the king
goes this way
i go my king i will i might
not be not uh to d5 immediately but i
couldn't maybe f5 first
and then i'm gonna defend my pawn on f5
let's say bishop d3 and i'm gonna play
this way
for instance bishop b6 again nothing to
do and king d5 and i'm going with my
king towards this pawn and i'm promoting
it
and this king is suddenly too far to
basically
support this bishop because this king
has to be defining pro f1 from queening
so because of those two weaknesses
uh the four weakness the two weaknesses
are basically
white past pawns b5 and f5 black is
simply
lost here and for instance just to show
quick uh as a quick example as a king
seven king c6 let's say bishop gets
activated to f2 frame for example
uh b6 bishop g3 from this side and again
we can play move king b7 or maybe even
we can play with b7
uh pretty much this should win as well
you can bring this bishop to e6 as well
at first
uh again do the rule do not hurry
applies on all those end games
as they can be seven at some point
followed by you know uh king a7 and b7
and this is uh this must be must be
winning there is no way that uh
there will be no no subscribe
however in the game follow something
different
in the game follow after f4 king f6 and
here i had the possibility
to actually take on g5 even after king
to hg5 taking a free
and the point is that right now i do not
want to have
a pawn f pawn but i want to have g pawn
i want to have this pawn
uh as a pass pawn to have those pawns g3
and v5
uh the passport even further away than
with the f pawn which is
which makes my text even simpler than it
was before
um let's say a bishop
b let's say in the game i have a king f6
and i play bishop c6 king e5
and right now i play move e4
and basically this is the correct
strategy uh because i want to trade
those pawns
and they have g pawn uh as a passport in
the game and if jfk e4
bishop takes e4 bishop b6 bishop c6
king g4 uh king h4 i begin pushing the
age and the
the g pawn uh king h5 have my opponent
resigned
because g5 g g4 g5 g6 is coming
for example again uh after this let's
say g4
there is no way the spawn cannot go get
to g6 let's say this this
this this suddenly this pawn on g6
uh keeps this king understand occupied
with defense of this uh
you know from to defend this g pawn from
promoting the queen
and right now by defending this bishop
this point the bishop at first
right now we can we have time to bring
our king towards the queen side
uh so not know d4 e4 but let's say here
and if here let's say we can play king
f3 even we can go like very long route
uh and there is absolutely nothing
black can do even like this it's not the
most maybe technical
but there is absolutely nothing black
can do and we just go in the light
squares finally we get there
and king supports this pawn to go to the
queen and the game is over
um so in this position after king h5
because of all those
possibilities those pawns being simply
too far away from each other
and this is winning for while my
opponent resigned
however here is one small caveat that i
wanted to talk about
if this pawn on g3 wasn't on g3 but
let's say it was on
h3 uh
[Music]
i don't know sure if i can change it
here on leeches it
quickly however
[Music]
okay i'll try to do it um
um one second
uh scroll down probably
no i don't know how how to change it but
but okay let's let's imagine
hypothetically spawn on h it's not on g3
but on hp all right
so um let's let's put it like this
to h3 so this end game would be actually
drawn
even though those balls are even further
away from each other this end game would
be drawn
and we'll see in a moment a similar
endgame that could have happened uh
in the game the prominent versus grish2
from the um
and from the you know opera rapid that
[Music]
in which this similar ending would have
resulted in a draw
and why is the draw because uh basically
black
black is very simple defensive idea give
up this bishop
for this pawn and keep this king on h8
and there is his emitted draw because uh
the pawn
uh the the bishop on six is a wrong
color bishop towards this h8 square
and this is immediate immediate draw
so uh having said that let's move to the
next game
and the next game i wanted to talk about
is
[Music]
ashney
in this game it was a very very very
long game
and uh for a very long time
white was better here she was much
better and
even here he was better let me just
double check it is there
it's there okay okay uh so
uh nepomeshi was pushing and pushing and
pushing for a win
and um but then he missed something and
they got this end game
which is very close to a draw it's
pretty much with correct defense just a
draw
so let's see how because she won this
game let's see what happened that he
managed to win this game
so king e2 logical right very logical
move king e2 bringing simply bring the
king forward to the queen side
king c3 is correct uh bishop d5
and right now uh grisham made
sort of unnecessary mistake i believe
because uh okay not a mistake inaccuracy
probably of course it was
uh with move number 54 both players were
under probably severe time trouble
uh so it was difficult to judge here or
anything
but anyway like king richard playing
with king d4 i think
just f6 was you know white to give the
pawn there's no reason to give this pawn
but anyway a king d4 happened which
takes f7 and but
right now uh this is a very important in
an instructive moment
uh for this game uh right now i think
grisham made a losing mistake
or from practical point of view losing
mistake
even though maybe com i i checked it
with english
and to according to my analysis unless i
missed something white is already
winning after
his mistake right now however if grisham
plays
king c3 simply right
i think that again the end game would be
uh
you know still
very very close to to a draw uh but
anyway there is no need there was no
need to
keep this to give up this pawn anyway
what i'm trying to say is what we have
to keep
called this king somehow contained here
and uh
do not allow this king escape because
what happened in the game that
here he played bishop and suddenly king
comes towards the queen side right now
kennedy took
c2 and even though
we may not seem immediate to win here
for white suddenly this king has
possibility to go around here
and get activated and
suddenly it's not not easy for black to
make a draw anymore
the game for bishop before king c2
bishop e5 and again just king e2
usually 6 trying to prevent the king
from coming but anyway
there will be some super fun let's say
we should g8 and suddenly uh
okay the repeated moves bishop g6 now um
it's the strokes from because upon on
the the three square is covered
the king cannot go there and if the king
goes anywhere else
i may because they're playing king c3
and if this bishop goes somewhere else
uh then you know uh i mean this bishop
has to stay on this diagonal
so uh two because otherwise besides
promotes
and then if this bishop uh retreats from
d6 then y goes king a3
and this was exactly why white i think
wins because after reach of c7
king a3 king comes king c5 king a4
and okay kim b6 so right now i think
they repeated uh
move positions several times this
doesn't matter this didn't change the
valuation of the position at all
eventually moved before
and uh this is all correct strategy
by the way all the repetition here by
nippomyashi is a very good strategy
because even though it seems like it
doesn't bring anything to the position
in reality it gains several festival
gains sometime
let's say if he was you know down on the
clock or something
he could have gotten some time by by
such a you know
you know strategy of repeating moves
and positions and this is one thing and
second thing
you are not declaring yet what kind of
strategy to play for when you uh to show
too early
and you don't want to let's say do it uh
whenever you have too little time
you want to have it you want to decide
on you know some action whenever you
have more time and you can actually
evaluate and calculate and so on and
also it keeps
there's also saying is this the
execution uh sorry the
thread is stronger than its execution uh
so meaning like that you know the threat
of let's say you're
playing before at some point is sort of
is in the air all
the time black has to always consider it
and uh
it may it may be in it may be difficult
basically to spot the right moment
uh to you know to
to kind of like to um to
face it in the proper way sort of so uh
after before a takes before king takes
before
finally uh never she played this
pawn break and right now the the plan
for white is to bring the king towards
this pawn
the king comes right off the queen side
if the king comes to the queen side the
game is just
over because punishment is lost and
again there are two weaknesses one
weakness is pawn h6 which is a weak pawn
and second witness is pawn on b7
more like the fact that pawn is white
one is on b7 because it restricts black
pieces especially this bishop or the
king
to being too defending here on this
pawn from queening so after uh and right
now uh
i was analyzing uh this end game i
thought that queen king c7
was a better defense and idea in general
here is to sort of
after for instance uh king c5 play move
king d8 and right now if let's say black
white plays someone like king d5 or
something like this kink e7
and again right now this could be a draw
why
because there is no breakthrough
suddenly there is i don't see a
breakthrough here for white
so this would be a huge save for for
grecia if he
managed to pull this off because after
king e4 of course king wants to go here
but then we go again king f6
so there are sort of corresponding
squares usually we talk about
corresponding squares in pawn
and games but here also in this end game
it applies whenever white king is only
four black king has to be on f6
whenever king has to be queen is here
the king has to be let's say here
and whenever king is on c6 also king has
to be on e7 so basically
black has to just stay on those two
squares e7 f6
with the king and there is nothing
absolutely white can do
because there is no breakthrough towards
this h6 pawn essentially white
has only sorry black has only one
weakness which is pawn b7 because
everything else on the queens
on the king side is totally blocked so
um
therefore um i think this was a better
defense to play king d8
so the question is okay so if king d8 is
such a great defense for by king e7 and
so on
how wide can i win because i was you
know i said is winning so
how i can win and the it's pretty uh
in pretty cool instructive i think uh
how i can win because i can play with
kim b6
and suddenly king a7 is a big threat so
so makes sense to play bishop b8 um
this is bishop b8 to stop this you know
king from going this way
and the right but but right now uh wide
winds in pretty much
an only only way only there's only one
way to win
f4 uh if nothing else again the skinny
c6 just king e7 and the
king sound is in time to you know catch
everything activity with f4 and so on
also as far as this game we can take
because there is no king a7
also after either f4 with bishop f4 of
course king a7 follows and white
promotes the queen
and after this i can go here and p8
queen next
uh so the only move is g takes the f4
and right now
white plays with g5 creates a second
passport on the king side
and exactly what the this is what we
discussed uh
in the game of um my game versus you
know
turkish master dastan
in which i had to create two past pawns
that are far away from each other
exactly same strategy here applies
by uh by nipponashi
in nepali so g5 so but the question is
what do we have to remove king e7
do we take on h6 or we play g6 and again
the difference is
extremely uh subtle but
basically one is leads to a draw one
this one is a win
so uh the thing is that after gtx h6 is
a draw
because why again a pawn uh or the
square on aj
is uh of the the dark square so the
bishop once he is pretty much useless in
that sense
so i can just bring my king to the king
side by king fight and okay if i bring
my king right now to g8 and hi this
immediate draw so normal move is bishop
e6 to try to you know
stop this king from getting to do this
square
however right now because we have pawn
f4 we can play with f3
and we can just you know uh
distract the white bishop from this uh
you know
task from of uh stopping the king from
getting to h8
after bishop ivanka in g8 this is
immediate drop because king has to h8
and we will give this a bishop for the
pawn b7
and this is immediate immediate draw for
example
this this this this b8
even this it i mean anything it's just i
just stay on those two squares and this
is just immediate draw there is nothing
absolutely
white can do to win
so that's that's pretty much
it uh on this gtx h6 however
therefore in this position the only way
move is to of course playing with g6
as uh we know we want to have two past
pawns
we have as far away as possible from
each other but
they cannot basically you know and
promote to the basically
the square of the if it's you know the
rook pawn
it can promote the square of the
opposite core of the bishop
our own bishop so g6 right now wins
because right now we easily stop pawn on
f2
and opponent four and uh black is not
able similarly as my game against dastan
uh to stop uh both pawns both b and g
pawns from queening for example
a free bishop h3 simply stopping bishop
f1
a king comes to c6 the g7 uh
probably at some point will be played
will be some tux funk as well
[Music]
the game is just decided the game just
decided okay
uh but anyway in the game for king b
skin c6 uh
okay sorry forgive me for king c7 was
the best defense
because then uh should have to find this
brilliant idea of f4
uh king b6 and now f4 it's not been may
not have been entirely easy to find over
the board
especially in you know in rapid the game
uh with limited time control
with being already you know long on time
however a great ship
kings which also seems like a logical
move but this idea this king c6 move is
not as good
because right now the skin cannot ever
go there because pawn promotes the queen
that's where that's why after king c4
the game is just immediately over
because white king gets
over this path towards g6 for g6 square
and h6 pawn
and the game is just over king b5 bishop
f5
uh usually was correct move
again we can just even give this b pawn
because as long as we get to h6 pawn
uh the game is just decided
we got this pawn and suddenly uh by
playing king h7 h6 king g8 there is
nothing we can do
a white can black can do the sub respond
h pawn from queening
h6 and starting bishop a2 and again
there is no way to stop uh h pawn from
queening
because bishop from abate has to move or
king has to move and then
king either g6 or g8 depending if the
king moves or bishop moves
and white white wins
so this is i think a very very
interesting end game
another end game that kind of like
brought my that caught my attention
is a very very old and classic game
between
mikhail finning and alexander kotov from
1955 i believe a very very old game
however the endgame is pretty much in
every chess textbook i believe
so but i would like to discuss this
position from
uh from yeah from here so uh
but finney went for such endgame
believing for sure that he was winning
and let me actually flip the board
because we are more stressing from
black's perspective this time
and um it seems like uh
this is uh this should be winning right
because
pawn be the b pawn is far away and
kind of meaning is advanced there are
all sorts of light squares available we
can for sure try to bring our king
towards this b pawn and win the game so
let's see bishop d4
bishop e4 followed we have to defend
this bishop king g3
finger 7 logical h4 also logical
otherwise you know
opponent will be object of the attack
maybe in the future and right now this
is the critical position
and um
may i i don't know if this was in some
textbooks or so for sure it was uh
but uh the thing is that i discovered
here one uh
nuance that um
i know maybe was missed i don't know
maybe it was a mess i have no i have no
idea
right now but uh anyway what i found is
destructive here
is that uh but phoenix move g6
right now by defining simply g6 pawn
g7 pawn trying to bring the king uh a6
f5 and so on towards the queen side
is ruining this position for for
for black and it's actually is a draw
basically right now
which is surprising but uh what it shows
is
that activity of the king in this in the
endgames and basically
tempo having you know like
having played you know very dynamically
and as quickly as possible developing
the ideas
um also is important not only you know
the rule do not hurry
sometimes you have to know when you have
to you know use calculation and
basically go for direct let's say uh
solutions rather than just you know
be like whatever let's just you know
play something and then think
uh here basically why is it very
important to
approach this push in in different
manners rather than
this typical do not harry rule the point
is
that uh if white king sort of gets to
the towards let's say d2 or something
white king will be able to stop his
b-pawn and bishop will try to somehow
stop those you know white's king from
attacking this pawn on h4
and and so on so it will be will be it
will become
pretty much difficult to to win this
position
and we'll see in a moment what could
have happened
however at first let's see what what how
bosnian could have won this game
uh king g6 is the boss the best move
king g6 and the idea is
of course to play with king f5 we ignore
pawn on g7
because what matters is uh okay first of
all why we ignore
we ignore the pawn because we don't
really need this pawn as much
uh as we because pawn on f4 is blocked
anyway by
bishop on e4 and what we need is to
activate the screen
king as quickly as possible towards you
know g4 or and uh
or r2 e4 and d3 and basically look at
this b2b point to promote
so after bishop c5 let's say analyze b3
bishop deforest i mean
you have to wait there's not much you
can do anyway bishop d3 bishop b2 and uh
[Music]
just some random random analysis uh
doesn't matter
basically at some point finding white
ghost king bug goes king of five
and uh we ignore this point on uh g7
because right now king e4 and as i said
uh king comes to c2 of course we can
stop
start with g4 first to you know control
f5
but any anyway king d2 kindly freaking
to false and b2 and the black wins the
the game and if king f2 black
white tries to bring the king after king
g6 also is very logical
now king f5 and the king g4 this time
comes in
bishop afterwards and simply be free
and suddenly it will be
uh funk because bishop can
has to defend both here and here but
this king is too far away from the spawn
to basically catch it and after king e2
if the
trying to get this king closer right now
uh black can be played with d4 which is
a key idea
in this entire end game um on similar
endgame by the way
but finn won this game eventually
because because because of made a
mistake
however here after it takes d4 of course
b2 promotes the queen
so bishop has to take but after bishop
takes again king is h4 and again we have
two past pawns which are far away from
each other
and this is exactly what black wants to
achieve in such position
again ideas uh of h4h3
uh you know
is unstable and right now even though we
have uh you know past
pawn on the uh the i mean rook past pawn
it is the h1 square is of the color of
the bishop we have
so this example where you know it simply
wins
uh this is simply when so this simply
wins for black
so this is what how black should have
played however both phoenix should have
played instead he played with g6 so
let's see
how what could white suddenly can make a
draw here
king f2 immediately bringing the king to
the king's side stopping spawn uh
something b pawn or trying to start this
pawn with the king and
this bishop is supposed to you know hold
those pawns on the
uh on the queen side this and the kings
are in the center so king
is logical king e2 king f5 seemingly
logical but suddenly king d2 and this
king is
just in time basically to stop this b
pawn and suddenly it is not easy to win
this anymore
because king g4 is made by bishop f6
obviously
anytime d4 happens we can take the e
pawn
because this king is very close to you
know the
uh this this b pawn here so after move
like king g3
in the game follow bishop e7 which is
okay
some triangulation which doesn't bring
anything absolutely bishop e7
of course uh one may ask uh why not
bishop takes before again bishop plays
b4 would result in king h4
and suddenly even though we don't have b
pawn anymore this h
pawn is well guarded especially but also
by the king here and uh black wings so
white cannot just give up this h4 pawn
it's very important to keep this pawn
so king g4 bishop v7 we should be five
body tries to you know maneuver around
we should have six king f3 a bishop b7
uh b3 and uh finally played b3
and now king c3 correct you know that's
why this king needs to be very close to
the queen side to start this b pawn from
queening
so king c3 bishop b6 is a very tricky
move because right now a king before is
impossible because of default
discovery right just to show it
and and yeah
and this position so right now uh white
to play and what a white actually can
make a draw and white can make a draw by
simply playing with key and d2 and
there is no way to break through here
with white as with black i mean there is
no way to make any progress
because um if
okay if king f2 or something i can just
wait king d3 i just wait a while to
square my king
and there is nothing you can black can
do because whenever bishop f5 falls i
merely go king c3
and
[Music]
and this is the resulting end game is is
drawish
for instance after remove kings let's
say king c3
uh already here uh but finney could have
taken on e3 right
so similar end game right so kim b3 is
the drop because after d4 we're gonna
say bishop c5
and uh i'm i'm stopping this d4 pawn
so uh after king e4 let's say i go kim
b2 i go back towards d2
and you know even if i lose f4 pawn
somehow like it will be a
total draw with a draw here so
that's why both kim d2 here would have
basically resulted in such
such droids end game however
in this position after bishop b6 kotov
made a huge
huge mistake he played with bishop c5
and this seemingly natural move because
why would i move my king from c35 where
i came here all the way from the king's
side just to stop this b
pawn so i would i you know
move my king back towards the center
away from the b pawn
if i can just defend my bone uh only
free with bishop
and keep on uh pressuring his pawn to be
free
and it appears to be a huge mistake
because as i said pawn h4 is the
critical pawn not upon b3 but defending
pawn on h4 is the
way more important than uh maybe way
more important but equally important as
stopping people
uh and b pawn pawn and the b pawn is
stopped
so it makes sense to keep you know pawn
h very well guard it
because bishop c5 after bishop c5 uh
suddenly black takes an only moment it
takes the
occasion the only occasion basically to
break through and suddenly black plays
g5 and with g5 uh
hg5 leads to uh lost position after gh4
and pawn goes to the queen
and if f takes g5 uh black pen black can
play move
d4 and again
we we're supporting this pawn b3 we want
to have the passport as far as possible
and after it takes d4 we play king g3
and we are winning this h4 pawn
again very important move because if
king f2 king here
d5 and bishop f2 will be a draw which is
very very close
but it xd4 king g3 is a very accurate
move
uh for followed by kinta's h4 and again
we have right now
two passports we'll have two possible b3
and h5
and they are simply going forward there
is no way to stop them
after bishop a3 king ty's h4 king d
freaking g5
uh g6 didn't change anything they didn't
wouldn't change anything just king comes
and pawn goes because bishop stops
you know here everything uh so
after bishop a3 takes in g5
h4 which is d5 here kotov resigned
because
[Music]
it is simply uh winning
position for uh for black
so yeah um i think that's
pretty much what i wanted to cover today
in today's lecture about
um opposite color bishops
i think there was also interesting
examples especially some
you know new discovery or support i
don't know if new but like
it's struck by this discovery by me uh
in this last end game of
kotov versus botfinik and
you know i showed also some interesting
strategies how to approach you know uh
from black's perspective how to how to
how to
not like some defensive side how to you
know
make a draw i'll quickly come back to
the game of
nashville uh here not this position but
the uh here with king d8 uh this line
whenever black doesn't why doesn't play
for his uh kim b6 and f4
and instead after let's say this this
just
one of us with the king so very often we
want to you know the corresponding
squares
we want to basically uh shoulder our
opponent's king from you know getting to
the squares where he wants to go
so lots of interesting ideas from both
attack inside and defensive side
uh in general those end games are not as
trivial as they
seem and there are lots of you know
hidden
maneuvers and nuances that are worth
discovering
and uh that's enhanced i decided such
topic for today's
uh lecture because i find it simply very
interesting
uh okay that would be all for now i'll
be back with the next
lesson of the next next lecture which is
on
um
games of the week and i will talk about
some games
from the recent tournament of opera
opera tour right from the
champions chess tour so opera rapid from
the champions chester
so stay tuned for this
thank you for watching and i hope you
enjoyed it
and see you guys have a good day have a
good evening